- Jean-Paul Belmondo.
- Demetrius Elder,
détective privé.
- Non.
- C'est un monstre sacré
du cinéma français qui nous
a quittés. Jean-Paul Belmondo,
c'est une carrière riche
qui s'étale sur 5 décennies
et compte plus de 80 films.
- Si vous n'aimez pas
la ville...
- Après avoir interprété
quelques petits rôles au théâtre
et au cinéma, sa rencontre avec
Jean-Luc Godard change sa vie
et son destin d'acteur. Avec
le film "À bout de souffle",
il devient une figure de proue
de la nouvelle vague.
- Oui, j'en ai marre.
- Sa collaboration avec Godard
se poursuivra avec les films
"Une femme est une femme"
et "Pierrot le fou".
- Qu'est-ce que j'en pense?
Quelle importance!
- Au cours de sa carrière,
il a travaillé avec les plus
grands; de François Truffaut...
- Je fais un sale métier.
- ... en passant
par Louis Malle.
Jean-Paul Belmondo était
également un passionné de sport,
un casse-cou qui faisait
lui-même ses cascades.
- Reposant.
- Son personnage
d'Adrien Dufourquet
dans "L'homme de Rio", dans
ce scénario librement adapté
des "Aventures de Tintin",
inspirera même Steven Spielberg
pour la création d'Indianna
Jones et des "Aventuriers
de l'arche perdue".
FRANÇOIS LÉVESQUE,
critique de cinéma, "Le Devoir"
- Il a réussi à concilier ces
deux types de cinéma qu'on pense
souvent irréconciliables, cinéma
d'auteur, cinéma populaire,
il excellait dans les deux
et donc, il avait son public
des deux côtés.
- "L'As des as",
"Le professionnel",
"Le magnifique",
Jean-Paul Belmondo,
c'est près de 130 millions
de spectateurs en carrière.
- Quatre, trois... un.
- Au Québec, il tourne en 1985
dans le film "Hold-up"
d'Alexandre Arcady dont l'action
se déroule à Montréal. Le jeune
Guillaume Lemay-Thivierge
faisait également partie
de la distribution.
GUILLAUME LEMAY-THIVIERGE,
acteur
- Il avait été extrêmement
gentil, doux, joyeux et très
rigolo avec tous les enfants,
on était plusieurs enfants
sur le tournage. Pour moi,
c'est l'incarnation
d'un acteur complet.
- Ne bouge pas,
laisse-moi faire.
- Police, ouvrez!
- Également comédien de théâtre,
il s'était produit sur
les planches au Québec,
notamment dans "Frédérick
ou le boulevard du crime"
d'Éric-Emmanuel Schmitt.
- Moi, ce que j'ai toujours
regretté, c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas eu assez de rapprochements
cinématographiques et théâtraux
entre le Québec et nous.
- En 2001, il est victime d'un
accident vasculaire cérébral qui
le laisse grandement diminué.
Ces apparitions étaient rares,
mais en 2017, Jean-Paul Belmondo
avait reçu un César Hommage
pour souligner sa
carrière d'exception.
Sur les réseaux sociaux, les
réactions ont été nombreuses et
unanimes. D'un bout à l'autre
du spectre politique français,
tous ont tenu à souligner
le décès d'un trésor national,
un acteur à la gueule et
à la gouaille inimitable.
Une carrière et un itinéraire
d'exception pour cet enfant gâté
du cinéma français.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.